bilingual people people who speak more
than one language develop dementia four
to 4 and a half years later than those
who don't cognitive Reserve is the idea
that people develop a reserve of
thinking abilities and this protects
them against losses that can occur
through aging and disease learning
anything new helps build cognitive
Reserve but there's something special
about language learning new languages is
an exercise of the mind it's the mental
equivalent of going to a gy every day
and it's not just our brains that
benefit learning new languages and
speaking more than one language is very
important not only for individuals but
also for societies learning new
languages can open doors to new cultural
experiences life opportunities different
people different communities and
different ways of seeing the
world